[Música]
bueno y aquí lo que está pasando es
la vía de expresión de quién se comió mi
queso
y le está pasando absolutamente todos
los sectores en la economía
y en mi caso si yo tiene mi queso ahí
era sólo mío lo dominaba totalmente me
lo comía despacito es más podía definir
qué tan rápido me lo comía y qué tan
rápido lo disfrutaba
y
y qué pasó si de un momento a otro él
quiso empezar a tener huecos más grandes
yo veo que ya no voy a tener que eso
y eso está pasando obviamente la
industria de medios de comunicación en
el mundo entero pero también por entre
un sector en el que ahora estamos
metidos en educación yo aquí
lleva una universidad de estratos bajos
y pasa lo mismo que pasa en los medios
de comunicación una industria
telecomunicaciones o en la de transporte
y es que pues estoy en una regulación
colombiana que desde hace más del siglo
pasado o inclusive del antepasado
y llegan nuevos competidores como
en los platos y si los cruceros y la
universidad de la rioja de españa y se
quitan y se come mi queso porque no
tienen una regulación que yo sí tengo
nosotros tenemos que cumplir con un
mandato que es del ministerio de
educación
y
y lo más simpático del mundo es que
voltee le digo a mi equipo bueno y
ustedes creen que la city y kurt sera
plas y son competencias nuestras no me
contestan lo mismo que algunos de
ustedes me contestaron el año 2011 y
2012 no es que yo tengo una licencia del
estado él también tengo una licencia al
estado y el uso del espectro y éstos me
dicen mismos que yo tengo una licencia
del ministerio de educación
y la verdad es que la regla de juego
cambiaron y por eso es que otro se come
mi queso y viene siempre el debate
regulatorio y la pelea regulatoria
el tema regulatorio pues pasa por una
cosa y es que por regulación no hay y no
va a haber
esto es un negocio sin fronteras
y les voy a poner un reto gigante y es
todo pasó por un tema como la relación
entre ese mundo digital y el consumidor
y quién tiene más credibilidad frente a
ese consumidor sus marcas o esas nuevas
marcas digitales
y la verdad es que si van ustedes le
preguntará a la gente hoy en día la
gente entrega toda su vida a ese mundo
digital todas todas todas todas todas
ustedes realmente eres en linkedin o en
whatsapp o en google entregan toda su
vida y es más allá del siguiente
ejercicio lean el contrato de prestación
de servicio de estas compañías y miren
sus propios contratos de prestación de
servicios y digan qué diferencia hay
entiendan desde el punto de vista
contractual que en relación cambia
y además lo que está pasando es que
efectivamente el ciudadano al consumidor
cree confía mucho más en compañías que
no tienen jurisdicción en colombia
ustedes leen el contrato de whatsapp la
jurisdicción que aplican la de
california entonces cómo es posible que
un ciudadano colombiano confía más en
whatsapp de que confían en sus compañías
o lo que confía más en la persona que
está al lado
cuando ni siquiera el marco legal aplica
en este país está batible es uno de los
de facebook que son grandes amigos y es
una gran compañía dirán no es que el
contrato whatsapp se aplica porque hay
un acuerdo que empezó en 1998 en el en
el doble audio que dice que yo puedo
prestar servicios transfronterizos y un
servicio transfronterizo y es verdad sí
probablemente médicamente de más decesos
pero efectivamente un consumidor
colombiano no tiene cómo poner una queja
hoy en día en whatsapp ni como la
superintencia industria comercio o un
regulador o un ministerio lo defienda no
es posible pues en el mundo regulatorio
pues qué está pasando pues una gran
crisis regulatoria y lo estamos viendo
en los debates del congreso de marzo
cubrir los de la última semana han
estado todavía más reveladores de la
crisis del marco regulatorio de esta
nueva economía digital pero esa crisis
arranca por una crisis institucional y
es que pues no hay instituciones
multinacionales capaces de regular este
esquema naciones unidas que han ido
discutiendo estudia por casi 20 años
alrededor del ayer el internet
governance fueron de cómo regular todos
estos elementos pues no no no no ha
llegado a nada y esta crisis
institucional pues pues se ha crecido
todavía más con trump que al que le
importa 5 que lo que pasa en ese marco
institucional internacional entonces ahí
no no no no no no pasa nada y no va a
pasar nada y algunas de las compañías
grandes le hacen lo de naciones unidas
pues pierden el tiempo porque eso no va
a pasar absolutamente nada nada va a
pasar algo va a pasar con las
recomendaciones de la ovd sobre
impuestos y eso hay que seguirlo porque
esta recomendación inicial de
de que está siendo la base de cómo poner
impuestos en la economía digital
hay que hay que hay que tener muchísimo
cuidado en eso sobre todo esto como
especial para que atiza al mundo
colombiano todo del resto no creo que
haya grandes cambios lo que sigo a ver
es una tendencia muy muy fuerte a la
autorregulación
y la crisis de facebook lo que está
generando es eso es que el facebook se
preocupe y acelere pues crear un marco
de autorregulación y el propio mark
zuckerber lo está liderando
antes de que termine el año tendrá su
primer consejo de autorregulación que
será el que defina cómo se regula
facebook
y el que además sea el que atienda los
casos casos específicos y casos
emblemáticos regulatorios de facebook
pero empieza a generar ya un mecanismo
que lo que quiere mark zuckerberg es con
el tiempo será un spin-off y que ese
regulador sea totalmente externo a
facebook inicialmente sondeado en un
trozo que paga facebook pero que va a
ser externo y eso eso muy seguramente va
a tener algún tipo de repercusión en el
largo plazo en el de maduración de
esquemas de autorregulación y van a ser
totalmente globales entonces yo desde la
cámara comercio internacional donde
tengo una posición al respecto ha
tratado de promover estos marcos de auto
regulatorios que ya existe en la cámara
de comercio internacional para muchas
otras cosas hace muchos años y hacer un
mundo digital no lo hemos logrado
pero pero había muy buenos debates sobre
sobre qué va a pasar
existe también una nueva fuerza que va a
hacer que la regulación se madure en ese
mundo y vitalista del tema inteligencia
artificial y el debate de la ética de la
tendencia artificial es que quien define
el comportamiento de las de las máquinas
o sea por ejemplo si a un carro auto
dirigido por una autopista
y se queda sin frenos el carro que
decide se atropellar a la viejita que
está en el carril derecho oa la
jovencita que está en carril izquierdo
entonces viene todo un dilema y como se
debe
programar esto es esta presión y a los
que se interese mucho este tema les
recomiendo el libro que se llama web un
soft más distorsión
luego tuve push web con software de
instrucción como herramientas
armas d
de destrucción masiva pero de
matemáticas y es presentan como los
algoritmos están matando gente o tomando
decisiones en contra de la humanidad
pero bueno pero saben es totalmente
irrelevante lo que ustedes tienen
totalmente irrelevante ustedes no pueden
cambiar eso y probablemente pocos podrán
participar en esas en esos debates o
influenciar los marcos de
autorregulación del mundo o los de
regulación del mundo la realidad de la
que soy y hay que hacer lo que nosotros
hacemos en la universidad y es salirnos
de la caja y tratar de operar en marcos
de orgullo regulatorio diferentes es
decir
buscar esquemas para poder competir el
tener el campo de juego justo plano
va a ser muy difícil entonces mejor
pasarse al otro
camps a la otra cancha y jugar desde la
otra cancha y eso es parte de lo que
tenemos que hacer eso lo que nosotros
estamos haciendo la universidad y por
eso el éxito de la universidad
eso lo que están haciendo muchas
industrias y después al otro lado
de la cancha porque pues la regulación
tradicional
es afecta mucho el desarrollo del
negocio pero aquí lo importante siempre
es ver
qué es lo que pasa con el consumidor y
qué es lo que prefiere el consumidor y
como tengo un relacionamiento con el
consumidor yo como conozco cada vez más
ese consumidor
y tradicionalmente hemos estado muy
lejos de ese consumidor y las modelos de
negocio esta nueva economía si los
conocen muy bien todo el tema de data
analytics el consumidor de villaverde
económicos estamos muy atrás y lo que no
tienen que hacer es desarrollar modelos
de negocio en el que ese
el modelo de estas centrales de
consumidores a ver todo ese consumidor
absolutamente todo y ser entender muy
bien qué es lo que quiere ser consumidor
y darle soluciones y entonces pues para
eso toca cambiar los modelos de negocio
muy seguramente pues según todo lo que
pasa en regulación en el mundo pero
al final del día mis recomendaciones
y pues hay que trabajar con ellas hay
que pelear con ellos hay que tratar de
que la cosa sea justa pero lo mejor es
salgan de ese marco regulatorio y operen
desde el otro lado
[Música]